Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a French horror
drama film called “They Came Back.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in an anonymous French town
where one day, a crowd of revived dead people
walk out of the cemetery, unexplained.
They calmly stream down the road in a silent
procession while the bystanders watch in astonishment.
As the crowd gets larger, the town council
holds a meeting to discuss the matter.
They, too, are as perplexed as the common
people.
The mayor reveals that the entire world is
facing the same situation at the moment and
no one knows what is causing the dead to come
back to life.
Initial estimates that more than seventy million
men and women have revived all over the world
and the counting is still going on.
In their town alone, almost thirteen thousand
people have come back to life.
The flow of the dead coming out of the cemetery
lasted for about two hours.
Apparently, the returnees include men and
women who have died in the past ten years.
After referring to the death registers, it
is found that the crowd consists of people
of all ages but more than sixty-five percent
of them are over the age of sixty.
One thing remains the same in all the revived
individuals; they are all in good health,
unlike their conditions before their deaths.
To keep these people off the streets and provide
them with shelter, the mayor requisitions
the local community center and warehouses.
He says that it is vital to keep all the returnees
together to identify them and send them back
to their families because they are now the
citizens of the nation and deserve rights.
The committee together estimates that they
have to keep the returnees in such facilities
for three to six months and dismisses the
meeting.
Soon, the dormitories start being prepared
where the individuals will be accommodated
according to their gender and age.
Among the revived individuals is the mayor’s
wife Martha.
Someone brings her to the mayor but he refuses
to see her and sends her home.
A member of the town council is named Isham
who had lost his 6-year-old boy, Sylvain some
years ago.
He and his wife Véronique go to one of the
dorms looking for the kid.
On their way, they see many “returned”
people who are being tested and interviewed.
The returnees seem to be void of emotions
as they stare into the distance and do not
indulge in conversation until they are approached
by someone first.
The couple shows Sylvain’s pictures to the
officials who ask them to wait.
They are also told that they can either take
the kid home or leave him in the dorm if they
aren’t ready.
When the kid arrives in front of his parents,
they are beyond shocked.
The scene shifts to the mayor’s home where
he meets his deceased wife for the first time.
She acts like she has never been gone, and
asks him why he is late.
Meanwhile, Isham’s coworker Rachel is in
her home overwhelmed by everything that is
going on.
Her husband Mathieu died in a car crash two
years ago but she has already accepted his
death, so she isn’t sure if she should welcome
him back to her life.
The following day at work, Isham tells her
that his son is exactly like how he was prior
to his death, he acts like nothing has changed.
He also asks Rachel if she plans to bring
Mathieu home but Rachel just dismisses the
conversation.
The town council holds a meeting again after
a few days.
They are now concerned about the potential
unemployment and housing problem in the future.
Moreover, the returnees are slow and they
cannot communicate well which means they are
not as efficient as they were in their previous
jobs.
The council also addresses that the revived
people suffer from effects similar to those
that may be seen after a severe concussion,
such as disorientation, sleep disturbance,
and wandering.
But for some strange reason, their motor functions
are unharmed.
Then, we are shown Mathieu who has returned
to his job as an architect.
However, he is sluggish in his job and only
speaks when people talk to him first.
Rachel has still not tried to find him.
Soon, another problem for the council arises
when the returned start to walk out to the
woods at night.
Researchers believe that they might be trying
to look for a familiar place or it could just
be a response to the traumatic experience
of dying.
To solve this problem, a doctor named Gardet
develops a sedative that only works on the
returned.
He also trains the security guard at the dorm
on how to stop them from wandering off to
the woods.
While observing the sleeping revived people,
he notices Mathieu dressing up and walking
out.
The security guard claims that he does this
every night and goes to his work.
The doctor finds this strange and follows
Matieu to his work.
There, he sees a group of returned people
having a meeting.
According to the watchman, they do this every
day.
One day, Rachel is returning home from work
when she notices Mathieu following her behind.
The two do not talk and simply make their
way home.
Doctor Gardet, who has been observing Mathieu’s
behavior, follows them.
Rachel is still not comfortable being around
her husband so she goes to her room claiming
that she has to rest.
At the mayor’s home, he organizes a party
to reintroduce Martha to the family members.
However, in between the dinner, she stops
talking and walks away towards the woods.
Her caretaker says that she has been walking
around the yard the entire day.
The mayor follows his wife and tries to bring
her back to the table but she continues walking
without any explanation.
Meanwhile, at night, Rachel approaches Mathieu
and starts a conversation.
She eventually kisses him and the two end
up having intercourse in the living room,
while the doctor spies on them through the
window.
In the next council meeting, a lady brings
up the fact that the revived people have body
temperature lower than a normal person.
Because of this, they are picked up by thermal
cameras as whitish figures.
So, the council decides to observe their activities
through the cameras attached to hot air balloons
spread throughout the town.
Their main aim is to find out more about the
nightly meeting that the returnees often hold
in different parts of the town.
When the first set of reports arrives, a surprising
element is found.
All the returnees, whether they be young or
old, cover a distance of at least nine miles
every day.
They end the meeting by stating when more
data is recovered they can point out the similarities
and frequencies of the returnee gatherings.
One day, Rachel and Mathieu are sunbathing
beside a lake.
Rachel, who was skeptical about Mathieu’s
return, is now comfortable around him.
The returnees in the lake can be easily identified
by their stiffness.
The couple meets doctor Gardet there.
He explains Mathieu’s behavior to Rachel
and tells her he is recovering quickly from
the trauma.
At night, Rachel hears a noise and comes to
her backyard only to find that the doctor
has followed them home.
On questioning, he says that he wants to help
her cope with the situation, claiming that
he knows how she feels.
He inquires if she knows that Mathieu wakes
up at night to go to his work.
Rachel says he just has trouble falling asleep
and insists her husband is normal.
After making him go away, she returns to the
bedroom and finds Mathieu awake.
He asks her if she was talking to someone
but she lies and says she wasn’t.
The next day at work, Mathieu submits his
work to his boss but his reports make little
to no sense.
Even when the boss explains his errors, Mathieu
doesn’t understand.
Hence, he is demoted to the technical part
of the company where other returnees like
him work.
In the following town council meeting, the
officials declare that the semi-normal behavior
that the returnees show is an illusion.
They have been imitating the expressions of
the living and following the memories of what
they used to do before their deaths to create
an illusion of being normal.
But they are not capable of innovative jobs
at all.
At night, Mathieu gets dressed without Rachel
knowing and goes to his work.
This time, the doctor overhears what the returnees
talk about in their meetings.
They seem to be talking normally about city
maps and areas around the town.
Meanwhile, the kid Sylvain wakes up in the
middle of the night and bangs on his front
door, wanting to get out.
His parents are worried about him.
The school has also informed them to take
Sylvain somewhere else because he scares the
other kids.
His mother cries saying that all he wants
to do is run away from them.
Similarly, the mayor’s wife also tries escaping
by jumping off a fence but the mayor stops
her.
The following day he talks to Rachel about
his wife.
He is worried that one day he will wake up
at night and she will be gone but Rachel claims
that it is their fate.
It is clear that all the returnees are trying
to escape from their homes and gather together
but no one can decipher what they are talking
about in their nightly meetings.
Rachel goes to doctor Gardet that day to ask
him how she can help Mathieu get back to normal.
But the doctor says that she can never bring
him back to how he was before he died.
The most he can do is remember everything
that happened before his death.
The doctor also shows her a clip of Mathieu
saying that he met Rachel two weeks ago when
he had been dead for two years before that.
Rachel loses all hopes of getting her husband
back and returns home only to find him missing.
Somewhere else, a security guard finds Mathieu
and other returnees in a field and asks them
to go away.
Just then, a loud explosion is heard from
nearby.
Following that, the returnees detonate several
explosions throughout the city.
All of them come to the street and make their
way to a tunnel.
The mayor wakes up to his wife missing and
drives around looking for her.
He eventually finds her in the streets and
forcefully gets her into the car.
However, the other returnees block him from
driving away.
Martha asks the mayor if he is tired.
When he doesn’t reply she inquires if he
wants to join them.
She has sensed that he is on the brink of
death.
As she calmly talks to him, he passes away
and joins the returnees.
Meanwhile, at Isham’s home, Sylvain is still
trying to escape.
His mother wants to let go of him but Isham
insists he will keep the kid forever.
As they talk, Sylvain falls off the balcony
from the second floor.
He stands up and joins a returnee man who
had been waiting for him.
In retaliation to the explosions, the military
responds by gassing the returnees with a chemical
that induces a permanent coma.
After guiding some of the revived people to
the tunnels, Mathieu makes his way back to
a worried Rachel.
He tells her everything that happened on the
day of his fatal car accident.
He remembers that they had a fight and he
took off in his car angrily.
When he returned home, Rachel was missing
so he went looking for her.
Knowing that Mathieu was looking for her when
the accident happened, Rachel cries.
She follows him into the tunnels, tearfully
kissing him goodbye before he disappears into
the darkness.
In the morning, the military carts away the
comatose bodies of the returnees.
In the last scene, the bodies are laid atop
their graves in the cemetery and slowly vanish.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.